[Music]
my name's charlie i live in london i'm
16 years old
i'm at college now i'm studying
geography politics history i like going
to the gym a lot uh reading i like
reading as well and uh i like just
playing around with my says i'm part
turkish cypriot and part british uh my
mom's side is texas
so i've always sort of known about islam
from like a young age that i think most
people do especially living in london
but i think when i first actually
started taking interest was uh early
teens i was quite enthusiastically
atheist my parents or anything they
didn't really talk to me about religion
and on my own accords just watching
youtube videos and stuff
i started off as being very
enthusiastically atheist and i didn't
really like the idea of religion but
then recently within the past couple of
years it's when i was interested in
islam
as well as christianity but i was
getting out of that phase i'd start
watching muslim youtubers and stuff like
that me and my friend in secondary
school would talk about islam and we get
into a little bit of debate just a bit
of fun but after that is when i started
really sort of looking into it like way
more than i even needed to
things about the mother all that kind of
stuff stuff that you know
isn't really necessary for a beginner i
still didn't know if i wanted to convert
for a while so when i started talking
again to my friend about islam he was
talking about you know you never know
what can happen tomorrow and someone
else my friend on instagram was also
telling me this because i was saying i
think next year i might try to fast for
ramadan you know it'd be nice to try it
out and then
my friend on instagram said to me but
it's not confirmed and i was like what
do you mean he was like you never know
what could happen tomorrow and that
really started to make me think and i
was like wow like you know it's not a
joke like if something happens tomorrow
never got that chance first of all i'm
very thankful for the donation it's
going to help me a lot with learning how
to pray and in terms of the experience
it was really peaceful it was really
helpful
and it was nice to do that for the first
time this is i mean it's a really
helpful resource like me if you know not
knowing how to recite sort of
things like that not knowing the
movements having it right there on the
mat being able to look at it and follow
as you go
i think it's really helpful it's really
useful especially for
converts
rivers new muslims thank you thank you
to the salaam team for coming out here
teaching me it really means a lot it was
a great experience
so i appreciate that
is to reconnect the world to allah
through salah you too can be part of
this amazing project and sponsor someone
you can help someone learn how to pray
so click the link below and sponsor them
now